Okay,
we are back live
morning.
Maybe I should do
maybe I should do a quick little
overview
just to get my thoughts clear because
I've been thinking about this pretty
much non-stop.
Um,
so there's all this off policy
literature, right, that's built around
sample efficiency
and there's on policy literature that's
built around compute speed, compute
efficiency. Um, and the thing that's
difficult to say is whether you can make
the on the off policy methods actually
work in the high data regime well or
not.
That's the thing that's tricky.
So, I'm trying to bring these two
together in a way that you can kind of
do both.
Welcome night in Vietnam.
I've never been to Vietnam. I do know
that you guys have good food there.
I'm going to try one
one small change I think
Okay. So, at least in this setup,
um, this doesn't make a difference.
Seems
course, it's like now we have a very
aggressively tuned baseline.
If I try the uh the on policy baseline,
right, we have this super aggressively
tuned baseline
where we literally have the fastest
training in the world on that.
If I do
I just cut the number of environments in
half, right?
Yeah. So, here's the problem, right?
Because the baseline is so aggressively
tuned, this actually is going to do
worse.
The whole problem with RL research in a
nutshell, right?
The batch size the batch size gets
smaller.
The mini batch size doesn't though
actually.
Got to just be something weird with the
hypers. No.
Actually, you know what? I have a
question. I have a question that I want
answered.
Let's see how fiddly RL is.
Um, when we just don't have
let's see like basically what happens to
reinforcement learning with our current
algorithm if we go to unoptimized dummy
hyperparameters.
I want to get a sense of that problem.
I just want to see what happens if we do
this.
Like what happens if we basically So
this is how most RL research is done
these days, right? Is people will just
use like defaults
I mean, look at like it actually does do
reasonably well. It's a huge difference,
right? So, at least we have stuff that's
stable enough that we can do that and
have it not break. I'm back. Welcome,
Rishi.
Okay. So, at least we expect
like some form of stability with this.
Okay. So, this is 500
591.
So, what happens if I just This should
be more
uh this should be like what smaller
batches.
This should be more fresh data, more
games.
Let's see what happens.
And it's a little bit worse, though
probably not statistically. So,
that's very weird to me because
like more stable.
Oh yeah, look at that. Okay,
so there is something to the um the
batch size.
probably something to do with just the
changing of uh of the LSTM state now.
Of course, you can't really learn
anything with this stupid tiny network.
I wonder if there is something
something to do with the LSTM.
Well, yeah, actually you do cuz if you
don't have we don't have frame stacking,
right? So, we kind of just need the LSTM
to be a thing.
Okay. So, actually that is better,
right?
We had to increase the uh the horizon a
whole bunch
to make use of fewer ends.
I wonder if now,
hang on, if I can go to one environment
and then leave the horizon at 256.
So now
now my question is
does this let you increase update epochs
or we just still in this case where
towel has to be super on policy.
Okay, so
we increase sample efficiency a fair bit
with default hypers
in just a few minutes of playing with
this, right?
But I suppose what is the
what is the question
from this?
Yeah. See, this is worse than before by
a lot.
It still actually does like pretty much.
Yeah, that's a solve. But
I think you're messing with the LSTM
state too often is the problem
If I really wanted to crank sample
efficiency, how would I do it
this
just going to mess it up more. No,
This would have to be an artifact. Well,
no, it's not just an artifact of the
LSTM.
You also do need the bootstrapping term.
Oh, I suppose can we like just crank up
the number of updates even more
question. Is it possible to place a flag
on an env
flag and building two-player turnbased
game
against other eval
beta
uh just mess with the clean puffer file
directly like in the eval loop there's
um you know there's a separate eval
thing like it's I think the function's
called roll out or whatever
we still have a rollout function
Okay. No, it's this one right here. This
eval function. It just has the loop
directly. Just load your model in right
here.
Like a few line code Change.
Yeah, this is way worse, right?
I guess we'll see if it um
it stabilizes,
but it's definitely not like
This maybe is just way too many gradient
steps though.
We can't do this many
Yeah. So this is how you make everything
super flow.
Yeah, there's definitely some form of
something like this, right? Of course,
it's going to nan out.
Got to like there's some form of this.
I'm sure
The problem is it's fundamentally
at least for the on policy case it's a
hardware inefficient setup
I'm trying to think where I take this
from here. Right.
the problem with how fundamentally
hardware inefficient a lot of these like
sample efficient focused methods are.
Like you literally may as well not use a
GPU for most of them. Of course, we nan
out still on this
still working on advantage. I'm trying
to figure out I mean I'm generally
trying to figure out how we bridge
computational efficiency and sample
efficiency.
I mean the behavioral clothing thing so
far
I actually did run a sweep on it
overnight. So, this has mostly solved
the task. And this is fewer samples with
untuned hypers um than my fast method
with tuned hypers and about twice the
time, which is not terrible.
Let me show you guys a cool result I got
last night.
So, I just reran the um
I just reran the sweep right on the uh
the method we were developing yesterday,
which is this like advantage focus
behavioral cloning thing.
So, we got up to what is this? 300 and
something. A bit over 300 score.
we haven't found any version of this
that really lets us like crank on
on the compute.
We could go grab those hypers and see if
we can get this to solve. That might be
a productive thing to do.
Okay. Well, we understand with this
experiment, right?
We understand with this experiment that
our current on Paul's pretty robust and
we can make it at least probably like at
least a factor of two more sample
efficient
already if we want to.
Then we have our onoff paw thing here
which is in
pretty much the same amount of time as
before with the untuned one. It gets 200
something score. And then there's a
tuned version that trains for longer
that can get over 300.
What happens if I go to two
environments,
make no other changes? This.
This is supposed to be more data
scalable, isn't it?
Yeah, but just doing this doesn't make
it better.
Fusion.
Ow.
How does that specifically help the
sample efficiency compute trade-off
thing?
Oh, wait. This is total
mini batches.
so then this shouldn't have done better.
But wait, if I go to this is two
and then I go to this is four. Does this
do anything?
The correct version of this I think
loads the learning portion of the um the
training like way more heavily, right?
That you like you can make the the
sample collection portion will become
less efficient fundamentally,
but the hope is that you make up for it
by being compute efficient on learning.
That I would have expected to be way
better.
was probably just super heavily
overtuned, right?
I mean, there's no reason to expect like
the
basic Q-learning version of this to work
either, right?
Does it make sense to go play with um
the BTR?
Yeah,
I think it's just really hard to beat
this on policy like a good on policy
baseline, right?
would the other angle that I have here
be to just try to make my on policy
baseline
um
more sample efficient
like bigger architecture and stuff. The
the problem here is that I've seen the
fundamental capability
like you need to be able to reuse some
samples
models
in behavioral cloning.
The model would be an independent
an independent improvement, wouldn't it?
The thing that I'm stuck on is how do
you reuse samples
without changing the whole algorithm to
make it slow?
Maybe we do just do the thing that I
planned the whole time before
No, we're not using expert data. That's
the point.
It's very easy with expert data.
We're trying to come up with um a
formulation of behavioral cloning that
works online. And the thing is that this
actually
the thing that's crazy is that this
actually kind of does work.
I guess the thing we don't know is
No, we do know actually that this works.
This works better because we're reusing
data. We know that.
What if instead of doing them
separately, what if I mix them?
That make any sense?
And now we should be able to play with
um
with one additional thing.
I'm basically just going to see what
happens if I mix on and off Paul data.
We store it by value. We sample by
advantage.
Do you see what I'm trying to do here,
though?
And I honestly wouldn't even be
surprised
if there's nothing magical about like
the Q function formulation with offpaul
both doing the same freaking advantage
estimate.
probably because I didn't do it down
here, right?
Okay,
so this should be
again roughly the same algorithm, right?
Yes, this is roughly the same algorithm
from before.
And now
let's see about the uh the losses that
we've got.
Make sure I haven't broken something
yet.
I did break something else here, right?
Because otherwise
otherwise this would work.
Changing robot from step controls to
trajectory.
What do you mean changing to trajectory?
You don't want to
as an issue one control sequence for the
whole trajectory. You definitely don't
want to do that.
That's like more classic control.
Change the return.
Oh.
Hang on.
Something's super screwy here. Now,
This must have copied something wrong.
Hang on.
[Music]
What did I screw up from before?
Oh, wait. This is not
Yeah, this is not getting optimized
Okay, because this is just our on policy
RL now here, right?
Yeah, this is just on policy RL.
This is our good baseline. We know it
works. yada yada.
What happens if we I'm curious. What
happens if we just sub this one little
advantage calc?
It's funny.
It's actually um massively worse to only
learn from the positive examples, it
seems.
All right. So, we'll do
we'll do we'll do this one.
I uncomment this? So, we have offpaul
data.
Looks like we haven't totally broken
everything, right? It still trains and
it trains better than uh before like
with our pure IIL thing.
Okay.
And we have
where our clipping coefficients in
There.
We do want our clipping in here for
sure, right? Betrays.
We're sampling by absolute advantage.
Oh yeah, this it's totally going to
change the um
it's going to change the hypers here
100%. Right.
Like if we wanted something closer,
we would do let's do like a basic one to
one.
Or actually, it's got to be it's got to
be double, right?
Oops. Not 120.
Not uh
uh hopefully that doesn't open this on
stream.
Come on, move the window. All right,
fine.
There's um there's an exploit going
around in Discord where I can't actually
ban all the bots.
Like they literally don't have
Is it in general as well
or did they just post it in dev?
Looks like just dev, right? I got that
one.
Thank you, Weston.
Interesting that this is worse.
This might just be the point at which we
need to optimize uh reoptimize hypers
and such.
I'm trying to think if this
what do we all think of this though as
an algorithm like
you just do on policy like you just do
your standard RL
you keep an extra uh you keep the extra
replay buffer
and then you trust uh PO clipping
important sampling and retrace
to keep stuff from going too far off.
This would kind of be way better as
well, wouldn't it?
Okay, it doesn't fix the roll out length
thingy,
but if we get this working
then actually we can fix quite a few
other things using this.
Yeah. Yeah. No, we can actually fix
quite a bit of stuff from That's
And actually, we should be fine sampling
absolute advantage like this as well.
Okay. So, let's see what other things I
could have screwed up in here.
Math heavy paper.
Conditional important sampling for off
policy. Let me look that up.
What the hell? No.
Get out, Google.
I understand that, but this is uh
this is a research stream.
The vibe is more like uh what you'd find
in an academic lab, man,
but with a heck of a lot more
engineering.
this might be kind of useful. I'm going
to have to read this like fully at some
point, but that's this actually might be
kind of useful because basically that
the offpole correction mechanism
is the uh the important thing There.
So we would just decouple batch size,
right? To do this efficiently,
we would just like decouple the batch
Five.
I think we actually have the core idea
in here now, don't we?
good online course way to get up to
speed.
Uh, no, but I have a guide. I have a
guide that links you to a bunch of uh of
good reading resources and things. It's
more peacemail. There's no single like
good course.
I'll link it to you.
If you go through this, you will
actually be qualified to uh if you
actually do this stuff, you will be
qualified to like advance modern
research and do a whole bunch of
applications. This is the exact thing
that like our top contributors have
done.
Okay. So here you see right if you don't
store any offpole data
we get the expected result. We can do
like anything. We can even like lo use a
tiny amount of offpaul data.
Literally, even the tiniest amount of
off policy data messes stuff up. Huh?
Like a little bit
when doing algo research is the uptime
your concern? There are a lot of things
I'm looking at. So there is the high
data regime
where you're just trying to solve the
task in the like lowest compute, lowest
wall clock you possibly can. And now
what I'm trying to do is I'm trying to
expand puffer to give it more axes on
which we can crank up compute increase
uptime uh but decrease sample usage.
the fact that you add just the tiniest
bit of data here.
I should be able to see it even more
clearly if I do like this, right?
Whoops.
and we don't even get 700 as a result.
Okay, let's see if we can figure out why
we decide to keep data based on value.
Right?
the sum heristic
and then it's sampled based on
advantage.
So if this data has
this data had low advantage
This does not make sense, right?
We have this tiny additional amount of
off policy data that we're keeping.
the buffer at the end. So what we do
here,
so we always keep all the on policy
data, right? And then you're also here,
I'll show you this is like a quick hacky
implementation,
but we keep all of the on policy data
and then we concatenate it with
additional data that we have in a
buffer. So the buffer consists of
however much off-paul data we want to
store plus the onpaul data and then at
the end
we uh we compute the value
where is it?
Yeah. So here we compute the value of
all the samples
and then we take the top k
and we leave these in the buffer. So the
idea is that we're keeping around our
highest value bits of data,
but it's a very small amount of data
either way, right? And like up top,
we're sampling by advantage.
So if the data is not useful for
training, it should just not get
sampled.
That actually make a difference or did I
just get lucky? Okay.
do one mini batch worth
data.
Now there's like a fair bit of off pole
Yeah, you need to update um
Oh, so this is going to screw with the
value function a whole bunch.
I see.
But you want to sample by a fresh
advantage estimate, don't you?
Oh, I see. I think it's cuz I didn't
maintain two estimates.
Does it matter what the original value
of the data is?
Like does the value loss clipping
matter?
What is the idea here with the clipping
of the value function?
Value minus.
Don't you explicitly not want to do
that?
I guess it depends what your motive is
here, right?
I mean the clamped ratio is still um
still differentiable, right?
Pretty sure the clamp ratio is still
differentiable.
more frequent updates of
Yeah. Um, this is the main thing, right,
is I haven't been able to get a good
setting where we can crank sample reuse
and really get much out of it.
It's actually quite difficult to get
that to work correctly.
Let's now increase the IL batch size to
something more reasonable.
That's like a reasonable amount of data
to keep around.
And it looks like it destabilizes
learning a bunch
like fundamentally why right we should
be doing
I guess it's technically possible I have
vrace done wrong
Well, I mean, that's just like you can
just throw that out there. What What
does that mean here? Right.
We have several different forms of
clipping
that are supposed to prevent offpaul
data from hurting us at the very least.
To be fair, this can totally just be um
this could totally just be the sampling
coefficients, right?
Yeah, this could totally just be um
prioritize replay screwing with this.
Hang on.
This is a problem with fancy algorithms,
right? A whole bunch of different knobs
that mess with you.
for now because we're not going to um
we're not going to like re- sweep this.
Let's do something that's more moderate.
that's like enough data that we should
Let's see if we see an interference
effect.
Okay. So, I mean it hurts learning, but
it's still it's still training like
reasonably.
Let's try a few different things here.
So like first
just set this to zero.
Recover our original
or update box.
See what happens.
you know, it really does feel like we're
throwing off our update somehow, right?
It really does feel like we're just
throwing off our updates. It's
Cuz otherwise this should be stable,
right?
Just curious here.
Does the uh the same thing as I saw
before or not?
Yeah. So, this return combat level,
right? The thing is with data reuse, you
should be able to actually get something
very quickly.
Is it just like overfitting it super
quick or something?
Is it ever a good idea to have learning
rate not decay to zero?
just increase next steps. I mean, there
are a bunch of different learning rate
schedulers, right? You could mess with
it. At least from the testing that I
did, it seemed like having a learning
rate scheduler was much more important
than the exact details of theuler.
Okay, so 20 million steps. We're already
up to
uh.13
013 return combat. So, it's actually
already learning a little bit, right?
Okay. Okay. So, what I'm curious about
now, if I set this to zero,
how's it compare? There.
Okay. Well, I think this is better. Um,
this is your proof here.
We'll see if this catches up. I don't
think so.
Okay. So, this is this is your uh your
proof of this, right? Um
we ran I think it was 27 mil before.
Give it 30.
We'll give this one even a little longer
to see
It is actually doing an okay job on its
own here.
was actually stable and did help a
little bit here
having um some previous data.
You would expect it to as well.
And this also this is one of the ones
that worked with literally just um full
off Paul data.
And this is with just a few samples of
it actually as well. I wonder. So, does
it get better or worse?
So, it could be problem dependent here,
right?
Can definitely be problem dependent.
Use
a restroom real quick. I'll be right
back.
40 million steps.
It's already getting combat levels.
Yeah, that's like ridiculously better.
Okay, so
here. It messes up. It could totally
just be the coefficients.
I don't even have pryo coefficients
There.
[Music]
like really just not stable or happy.
Um, we have it so that it's it appears
to be doing substantially better on our
hard task of neural MMO,
but having a replay buffer, it's very
very fiddly with even like breakout.
Does breakout work if you just crank up
to deox?
It should just not pull from the data
though if it's not good.
like it's uh it's already being sampled
reasonably
the breakout with just eight update
epox.
One of the other wonky things about
Breakout is the episodes are so long.
like basically only getting to play one
full game in the whole training even
though you're training this long
But you like almost get no sample
efficiency improvement. Almost none
out of eight update epochs.
And then it hands out. Well, I say that
and then it hands out right at the end.
Cool.
Just the brink of being stable, I guess.
Okay. What about eight update epochs on
um with all this IIL data in here.
Then it just decides like actually never
mind.
I could compute like fraction on and off
Paul I guess.
Yeah, it really does get messed up
though by this oddly enough.
I think it gets messed up even worse
than if you just give it um if I just
give it one epoch, right?
Believe this is fast and
literally gets messed up
worse with more epochs.
Oh, also experience replay has this
weird decay,
right? It has like this weird decay
where it goes to it tries to go to
uniform by the end of it, doesn't it?
Yeah. But we don't want that for this.
It could totally just be the sampling,
right?
Something tells me it's not just a
simple have to reweep, but we can try
that.
I guess we basically see by the end of
this
does
I mean, it does seem weird to me that
it's like that
that screwy.
Um,
on the other hand, it could literally
just be the uh the prioritize replay,
right?
like breakout is kind of just a a pretty
on policy end because
well is it
not really right? You're kind of doing
always the same thing in response to the
ball just trying to hit the ball
but the episodes are really long.
Okay. Well, the other
there are so many big problems with
this, man.
I think what's the next productive thing
I can do on this?
It could also work on the new end test
for For whatever reason, it like
just don't believe that it's going to be
better if I just switch from this to um
a Q-learning based thing, right?
Like technically I am doing something at
this point that is very much a uh
like an offpaul type thing.
Am I totally wrong to think that
that like if I just go for um
do you learning based thing it's not
going to be better.
We did get like
the base DQN actually did kind of work.
Well, it worked on the simplest possible
problems.
I guess I could do that next.
And realistically, I I'm not going to
sit here and wait for a sweep to run
today. I'm going to actually I'm going
to end up overnighting it. So, I may as
well take a quick look and see if this
happen to do. Yeah. So, like you do
something, but so far you don't really
do anything amazing.
I guess the next thing to look at would
be
just
forms of Q-learning.
Yeah. So this is this I understand this
is the key thing here right the problem
is that the off policy methods the
theoretical guarantees are there um
without the multi-step bootstrapping
bootstrapping but the algorithms just
suck
and then when you start bootstrapping
you have to do all this off policy
correction crap that's not actually
making use of the data.
So essentially you just you end up with
a algorithm that can theoretically reuse
data but is just worse than your on
policy algorithm.
That's the big problem as far as I've
seen it.
Right.
That's the big problem I've seen.
Does SACE have a smart way of dealing
with this? I've never used SACE at all.
Okay. So, this actually does give you a
nice sample base thing, right?
wrong prioritization.
Yeah, it can as well.
I guess it's kind of crazy that SACE
even works, right?
I didn't realize SACE, they literally
have a onestep bootstrap in this thing,
right?
Could I not make a version of this like
really fast?
If it's literally a one-step bootstrap,
right?
Why don't we just go grab this thing,
I'm kind of curious.
is to like
EQN plus prioritize play
single experience level.
I don't think that does work
phenomenally good. I think that's like a
super [ __ ] like algorithm, isn't it?
Literally, you have baselines for that
stuff.
Like if rainbow and po are supposed to
be competitive,
prioritize replay is like one of the
tricks that like is it's way worse
without. There are other tricks that
it's way worse without as well. This is
the problem is you actually need like
two or three major improvements before
you even get close to um like pretty
basic on policy methods.
Nothing close to PE but for off policy
it's good. Well, that's a useless
algorithm though, right?
Like if you're underperforming base PO,
that's a useless algorithm.
And the problem is that there are a lot
of useless algorithms in off policy. And
you actually have to bolt a bunch of
crap onto the base things before you get
something useful. Like here,
this thing actually looks kind of good.
Okay, so this takes
This takes rainbow, which is already a
kitchen sink of random techniques, and
bolts on six more techniques. It removes
two. So, it brings you to 10 additions.
You have 10 additions to base DQN before
it's a usably good algorithm.
Is this literally intended for one
environment?
You've got to be kidding me.
SACE, it's literally set up for one
environment. That is the dumbest thing
I've seen in a long time.
I wonder if their implementation even
works for batched um
batched environments.
Why does it always insert a random ass
character when I open a file? Drives me
insane.
It gets slower and slower and doesn't
print reward or anything.
Yeah, they also they assume a specific
format of stuff.
I honestly don't think this is going to
do anything. Like it's just
it's such a screwy regime of algorithms.
Like the majority of RL is just in such
a screwy regime. It's like I forget that
it's I always say, you know, puffer is a
thousand times faster. Puffer thousand
is a thousand times faster. It sounds
like a marketing ploy, but like you
literally just run defaults on stuff and
it's actually a thousand times faster.
So, I don't
That's next. Yeah, exactly. That's the
point. You can't It killed the entire
field and everybody went over to work on
language models because you can't get
anything done at that speed.
Now try to make it a thousand times
slower and have 10 times more code
because no researchers can write code.
Like clean is the best thing out there
by a mile. It's actually simple. It's
just slow.
Like honestly, the whole field owes a
blood debt to Costa for actually making
this exist in the first place.
Probably without Clean R, I would have
given up and just said this field is
stupid by now. At least clean gave me a
starting point for like, okay, I can do
this but fast.
Don't use a lib torch like the C++
because literally nobody will use puffer
lib if I do that.
H funny.
Yeah, I the thing is it's C++ but I
don't even think it's like good C++,
right?
It's not like this magically works,
right? It's just super slow
to steer towards and reach your goal.
Very easy with large step size.
Lower step size, better rewards. Uh
yeah, there is a thing. So, you're
increasing the credit assignment
horizon. So, the smaller the steps are,
the harder the credit assignment is. Um,
if you need it to be small step size to
be accurate, you do some sort of
curriculum learning thing, just start it
near the goal and then, you know, move
it farther away over time or like
randomize distance from goal, something
like that.
It'll solve
Okay, so this is just getting slower and
slower and is not even solving anything.
It's really not even worth messing with
anything in the hardware inefficient
regime, right?
Like you're just back to square one with
like RL being a super cursed field where
nothing makes sense.
I mean, this is literally running on
like what 1% GPU utilization.
is the thing that killed the field in
the first place.
This is kind of cool. At least this is
up to like 500 or whatever under this
circumstance.
Okay, I don't know what the point of
this exercise was other than to remind
me how ridiculous everything is.
But you see what I'm trying to do,
right, Tim? Like
we do need to bridge the compute and
sample efficiency gap somehow.
And like realistically the only way to
do that was with massive sample reuse.
Because here's the problem, right?
If I run a ton of parallel environments,
um, I don't really get to update my
policy very much before like to get
fresh data.
Like you can't really do sample f with a
ton of parallel ends.
So the forward pass is just going to be
slow.
maybe we just go over to some of the
offpaul stuff in puffer
robots and imitation. Imitation on its
own is easy.
It's like the mix data collection
setting that's hard.
Even with puffer, I got 10 FPS.
Yeah, you definitely definitely 10 FPS
is uh something's wrong.
Should never be 10 FPS.
Does anybody know um Soft Actor Critic
doesn't do a distributional thing,
right? Does anybody know how the hell
soft actor critic works without uh
distributional RL in
Okay. So this is the basic
uh cart pole thing.
Got my RL exam on Monday. I forget that
there are actually RL courses out there.
you end up so it's like kind of Kevin
uh you can actually get something to
kind of work literally just doing
behavioral cloning on like best data. I
also this morning here what I did is I
took that and I integrated it
um well I took that and I basically
added a a buffer to the existing puffer
online RL which seems to be doing better
and I'm relying on um a couple different
off correction mechanisms to keep it
stable and it's done like
it's done Okay, the thing that's weird
is I actually have it making neural MMO
learn way faster, which is like the
hardest environment,
but just having the data around at all
seems to make it harder for stuff like
Breakout. I can't figure out why.
like it should just not sample um the
offball data.
I mean, I I got to give this an honest
try. It's so far-fetched in my mind that
like you would be able to get anything
out of a one-step bootstrap.
I didn't actually realize that the soft
actor critic doesn't. It's literally
doing a onestep bootstrap, but it's so
hard to compare because it's like the
most inefficient thing ever conceived.
Saved.
The problem is the endstep bootstrap
actually doesn't really work.
Behavioral cloning filtering
filter with advantages. Yeah. So, uh,
the thing I did yesterday was just store
all the data in a buffer. Um, and
like keep the highest value data, not
advantage. I believe I did it by uh
return like trajectory reward sum plus
uh final value.
And then you sample it by advantage and
you just do behavior weighted behavioral
cloning which looks very similar to
onpaul RL. And then today what I did is
I just literally did the on policy RL
but I just do it with an additional data
buffer that you can sample from.
And then I'm hoping that between
clipping and well the fact that between
clipping and uh the vtrace component
that's already embedded in puffer
advantage that it keeps the data
generally useful
which it should to be honest because
like the advantage computation should
just go to zero or whatever if it gets
too off policy because it stops trusting
those samples I would think.
I'd have to double check. I'm pretty
sure that's what should happen though.
Was that advantage weighted regression?
It was similar.
Let's say
I'm just going to have to go to the
other environment build stuff soon.
direction with one policy with clipping.
Does that mean you also sort old pi
waiting for all the data in the buffer?
You just have to store the log prob of
the action you selected, right? That's
all you need.
I mean, I guess you could technically do
full KL div, but I'm pretty sure it's
just you take the log prop of the action
that the old policy selected, you
construct a ratio with the uh the new
probability, right?
You could model the full distribution,
but I don't think that's the normal
formulation.
Oh, I just have this set up in like a
totally weird way, I think, for um
I just have this set up in like a
totally
weird way for this
It almost makes more sense to go off of
the clean RLSC initially.
And just tack it for now a little bit.
Keep pushing on it just a little bit.
I'm not really trying SACE. I'm just
trying to get something with a onestep
bootstrap to do anything.
I don't know. I'm messing around with a
bunch of different things at the moment,
Kevin.
Like, honestly, the whole literature is
just screwed.
Like, it's completely screwed.
be 16k.
Should be 16.
Okay. So this is now batched.
This is like batch Q-learning. Yeah.
Okay. Not amazingly stable, but it's
it's a thing. It's there.
So, how is this supposed to do?
What does SACE do on top of this that's
so special?
that like everyone always shows it
matching roughly po
Next log.
Get action on obs
of X. Okay.
So, this actually
Oh, okay. So, there's a separate actor
in a soft Q network.
trying to derive the entirety of RL.
It's not that I'm trying to derive the
rederive the entirety of RL RL
literature from scratch. is that I'm
trying to figure out how to make the
things actually work because I mean if
you try any of them, none of them
actually work.
I'm trying to fill in a bunch of holes
basically.
I mean, we could make a version of this
fast, right?
Yeah, we could make a version of this
You got like Well, you can get rid of
some of them.
This is like the double
the double DQN thing right here.
So, there are other like there are other
offpaul variants where you get rid of
two of these. Um,
I'm more confident that if we make it
work, I can come up with workarounds to
strip things out and make it fast. Uh,
the question is whether this actually
does much on its own.
Literally best thing is going to do it
would be though for me to um like start
from 300 fresh again. Annoyingly enough,
the thing that I didn't realize. Okay.
So, the the key piece of missing
information that I didn't realize here
was that Soft Actor Critic doesn't have
a um a multi-step bootstrap and somehow
does Okay.
Right.
That was the key thing that I didn't
understand.
Okay, let me use a restroom real quick
and then we'll try we'll see whether uh
this does anything.
I should be able to get this to match PO
but fast. We'll see. I'll be right back.
I have some ideas of how I'm going to do
this.
Okay. So, we have all these little
networks.
not normalize my observations. Do I not
have that in the checklist?
I'm pretty sure I have that in the
checklist.
Normalize your observations.
Are you using reparameterize?
Are you using reparameterization trick
to back propagate through actor
through the actor update?
Um,
no. What I was doing here is I have I
have the four fully separate uh Q
functions and then the actor just has
its own LSTM
and the Q functions don't.
What reparameterization trick
through the actor update? I haven't even
gotten there yet at all. I'm literally
just setting up optimizers.
Yeah, you just need to store actions.
No values to store.
And I think we're already at the
training loop.
Yeah. So, we are at the training loop
and
we're going to just ignore
all this advantage stuff.
We do actions like this.
Then we need
this right and then this doesn't take
this is fine
use action probabilities
and then
next state action prop
you want full action props I guess.
Yeah. Does that just log softmax?
So is this not just um
this is just soft max of log jets right
wait next state.
Next state.
Oh, this is on next observations, I
suppose.
Okay,
because it's going to be action robs
times
Okay, we'll see if I've done this
correctly. Probably this is the uh the
crucial don't screw this up.
Okay. So, we have to now be careful with
this, right? Because this is
the reward.
This is the one that I have to be
careful with, right? Because it needs to
be the next target. So, it's
this I believe.
And then this will have to be like
The torch. No grad.
So this whole thing is under a nood. Red
That's so inefficient the way that's
implemented.
Okay, we'll have to change that. We can
at least share some of this.
I think it is something it's something
like that.
And this one's got to be like
this, right?
and now we do it again some for some
reason.
I mean, this is still
this is actually going to end up being
less complicated than the current
implementation of the algorithm because
of the lack of prioritized replay. Of
course, as soon as you go stick that
back in, it gets worse again.
And now this thing here, here's your
actor loss.
Is there anything else?
No, just the target nets.
Oh, it's just um that's just for
retuning. Fine. We can ignore this for
now.
All right. So, now we get rid of all
this stuff.
like kind of okay.
Tons of stuff we can do here.
It's going to look something like this.
We could very easily clean this up.
Okay, we're actually getting like
reasonably far into the algorithm Now,
Why is action props like this? Yeah.
Oh, cuz logits
Wait, what? This looks good to me,
doesn't it? Now
Just do
go up one target.
Want to get something to be useful
today.
Then
of course this chunk here.
This this
crazy they use four separate Q functions
in this thing
and
this is probably the exact same thing as
before. Yeah,
we'll actually be able to reuse a couple
of these computations though.
So, it'll get faster, but even like
this, it we should still be able to get
like a million steps a second or
whatever.
Okay. Well, that is the initial
implementation.
The initial implementation right there
doesn't seem to do anything.
But we do have we have it running and
it's actually running pretty fast.
Now we just go bug hunting right.
Oh well, I didn't sync the damn
networks. That will do it.
target network frequency.
Yeah, this whole like Q function
synchronization garbage.
8,000
target network frequency.
and towel.
They have this thing set not to one.
Go look at the uh the clean RL1.
See what I've missed.
Why do they do a categorical followed by
a sample here?
Oh, because they this is Yeah, we have
this as well. This is fine.
But this takes policy parameters
with two parameters.
Then this takes
what the heck? Where' the target
optimizer go?
Wait, wait, wait. What? Huh?
Oh, no you don't. you just get
right the target just gets copied. It
doesn't get optimized.
Um
and then the actor optimizer needs the
encoder, the decoder and the LSTM,
right?
Okay,
have all this stuff
and we get to training.
Okay. So, we have to make sure we did
next observations correct, right?
So, I do on MB ops, we do a sample
do view logs.
Get action.
So then this can go
wait
this actually can go in this whole thing
can go into this nrad loop right
this whole thing goes into the nrad
do men
alpha And then this is next state log I
Now we do
Q function
one. The target Q function on next obs.
Okay. So I've done this on current obs,
but I have them in a buffer that's going
to get shifted by one. Anyways, we do
this min alpha next state log pi. Okay.
So I think next state action probs
action probs and state log pi log log
action probs.
And then you sum along this dim
and then you take
you offset it right. So it's plus one
minus terminals.
gamma
+ 1 - m times yeah this looks good to me
and then
you do this q function I don't know if
this gather is correct we'll double
check this
okay but you you do this and then you
have a q function loss which is mean
squared error between
next Q value,
which is already offset by one. Okay, so
I think this looks good to me.
And then this we don't care about.
Yeah, this looks good to me. Let's go
make sure we're doing this this sampling
operation. I know I've gotten wrong
before.
Let me see if this looks Good.
So we do one
zero
one.
Wait, what? Hang on. One 0 one one. So
one 0 one
one. Yeah, this actually looks correct
to me.
Yeah. No, this is correct. So, huh, the
gather is actually correct here.
What do I have? Uh, what do I have wrong
then?
Did I delete all of them already? Hang
on.
Well, it doesn't blow up or anything.
There's another loss though, right? The
actor loss.
are both reasonable
numbers.
Let's check if the update frequency is
something totally obscene.
How often do they update the target
network?
They update the target network frequency
of updates for the target network.
which is in their case
that is
quite uncommon because
like a hundred something updates, right?
And then what is this target entropy
scale?
Just making sure it's not a terminal
issue. Way easier to catch on breakout.
But yeah, no, this doesn't learn
anything.
Welcome tree form.
I'm currently messing around trying to
get um SACE into Puffer LIIB so I can
run some comparisons.
This is definitely not learning.
Well,
the rewards kind of goes up, but it's
like it's below the noise threshold
really.
The thing that I hadn't realized about
soft actor critic, I figured that it had
um like an endstep bootstrap
like all of the other off policy
methods. Uh but it doesn't. It actually
does
well. I guess it depends what papers you
believe, but comparably to PO with
uh only a one-step bootstrap.
Of course, I need to actually get it to
do something for that to be uh evident.
So when you collect uh where you step up
the end.
Yeah. You just want to collect the
actions, right?
So we actually
Yeah, we actually do not care very much
about any of this. Let's get actions
man. So we can just get over here,
right?
We don't need this. We don't need this.
Right.
Some ways, if this works, it will
actually simplify things a little bit.
So this should just be probs log prop
like this. Yeah.
Prob log prob yada yada
prob.
Uh, this needs to be
Oh, and log prop also needs to Okay.
now this does need to get reshaped,
right?
You
Hub.
Oh,
hang on.
Okay. So, this is now running.
Still doesn't train.
Really?
You do all that, it still doesn't train.
programming would not be fun if it
worked the first time all the time. I
disagree. It would be dramatically more
fun
because I would just solve one thing,
move on, solve the next thing, and then
all the problems would be solved.
I think if there's like anywhere obvious
I would have messed
Hang on. This this is on obs
actions, right?
Next Q value.
You sum these. Yeah.
And the next one is going to be acquired
by
Yeah, I think this is fine.
Rewards
of
This seems fine.
That seems completely fine.
That's all there is. Like there's really
not that much to this algorithm.
me in on this
min q function values.
This one doesn't need to be offset.
Right.
This one's good.
We use action props for temperature
loss.
No, this is not needed. It's just a
fixed alpha.
Oh, okay. It's
the fact it's jumping around.
It's probably doing something.
Might need to just fix a bunch of other
things.
Just to be sure that it's not just this
jumping around the scores.
Oh, it's not it. H
I still have bugs in here then. Yeah,
it should pretty much any reasonable
algorithm should jump above uh above
seven
almost instantly.
It is weird that this is slowly ever so
slightly going up, I'll say, but
result
like even directionally.
You can probably just maximize entropy
and do better than this.
Yeah, but like it should
any reasonable algorithm should have
solved uh should have gotten it way way
before then. Like you can literally run
vanilla DQN and get that immediately.
Let's see if it's consistent or just
jumpy.
Okay. So, let's get this to be stable
and see if we can run it on breakout.
I don't know how frequently we should
sync.
Like do you want it to be synced very
frequently or is that screw it up?
tow equals
05. Does that make a big difference?
believe so. Okay, we'll try that. It's
weird because the cleaner defaults don't
even have um they just have it set to
one.
I mean, it's possible I still have major
problems in the implementation as well
here, right?
Yeah, cartpole is like so incredibly
easy.
You can have stuff be completely wrong
and just still kind of do stuff on that.
Are you just supposed to run way more
updates?
Four neurons.
Yeah, you can solve it with um you can
solve it with four neurons. Sure. I
think it's maybe Pong is four. a lot of
the Atari is six,
but that's not really the point of Yes.
See?
Figure out what it is.
And just mess with the hypers a little
bit.
I mean, it should just like
literally Q-learning works on this. It
should totally work.
No, that actually breaks it instantly as
well.
This stuff is like pretty basic though.
Now
the value
the loss
minus
in
as far as I can see, I have this set up
correctly and it's like really
underperforming.
somehow works on just cartpole.
Guess the easiest problem
and not even super consistently.
Yeah. See, like that's a mess.
This should definitely
definitely like work way better.
We do use MB actions here. Yeah,
that was the one thing I wasn't sure is
if I had grabbed the uh the actions
correctly.
Next Q value.
This is a gather.
Nothing else in here.
This is literally just a sample.
Target loads the state deck of the uh
target loads the state deck
of
fine.
I like not optimizing the main network
somehow.
Encoder decoder
the self policy. Got your encoder. You
got your decoder. Oh,
that's bad. Yeah. Okay, that'll do it.
Hang on.
Yeah, hang on. Hang on.
Like they actually they should be the
same, right?
Hang on. Yeah, I thought I'd seen
something, but it's that's not it.
I mean, then it literally wouldn't be
able to learn
Yeah, it's the LSTM weight that you
want.
Anyways,
that's it.
player norm.
Uh I don't have a learning rate schedule
on this actually, right? That's kind of
a big deal.
How do you make soft actor critic
actually learn something
this one doesn't take
I don't know if that changes anything.
actually don't think that does change
anything.
Heck,
we just are we have to search over
random seeds now. Is this where we're
at?
where's the
this gather here?
Yeah. So, this Q function doesn't use
how can you tell her the score?
Yeah, it's the score. So, cartpole, you
just get a point for every step until
you fall over. And if you get 200
points, then you're balancing it
perfectly.
Something is just wrong. I don't know
what.
trim both of these against the same
target here.
Do this gather which I double checked
this gather and this but gather is fine.
do policy
Q function one Q function two
boards plus 1 - done times gamma
in Q function on the next steps do next
Min of the two targets minus alpha
prop
have
log prop pro log prop here from ours
is so incredibly difficult to get right.
Is it a bug? Is it the hyper suck? Does
the algorithm suck?
all over the place. I mean, it's like at
least there's something correct here.
Otherwise, you wouldn't get um you
wouldn't see any learning, right?
adjustment of weight. No, if you
randomly are adjusting weights, you
won't get a you won't get a score like
this.
It's like directionally correct at the
very least
and I don't but I don't know like what
is
I have no idea what the problem is,
right? If it's just hypers, if I have a
bug Hug.
on the original code.
The problem is these are like these
algorithms are fancy enough that you're
not going to ever really be able to do
that. Like if you're never going to be
able to really get like one to one
comparison like this. What's the
baseline score with PO instantly solved?
Like by the time it's printing out logs,
it's already solved.
And this thing should just have
instantly solved everything.
Especially like I'm giving it so much
more fresh data as well.
13 seconds.
Yeah, exactly. I mean, on a faster
machine, it'll like be basically
instant.
Okay. I mean, this does do something
now, right?
The hell could I have possibly done
wrong here?
are the Q I mean no it shouldn't matter
that the QETs I have kind of suck
And nothing.
Nothing at all.
Uh, why the heck did Reream just sign me
out?
Okay.
Well, whatever. I got it now.
when you were at Stamford or I don't
know MIT for your undergrad. Stanford
was undergrad. MIT was PhD. Do you have
like people who are admitted to school
with bad grades
accepted due to impressive
extracurricular?
Uh, I don't know about impressive
extracurriculars. I definitely know a
bunch of people who I have no idea how
they got in.
It's tough to get in with bad grades
because it's like
having bad grades. It's like it's such
an it's such like a a basic checkbox.
It's like failing to get up and tie your
shoes in the morning, you know, on the
way out.
I mean, there's like a huge gap. Like,
you meet people who are absolutely
brilliant, right? And then you meet
people who are like, "All right, this
guy's a [ __ ] I have absolutely no idea
why he's here, but okay, I guess.
Well, yeah, let's just go get grad.
Norm.
me just one thing real quick.
Tab zero grad. I don't think it makes a
difference
unless I you know it's possible I have
my loop set up differently
because that wouldn't make any sense
though, right?
Yeah, cuz it has to be optimized
obviously, right?
Otherwise, you wouldn't see if I had
that as a mistake, then you would
literally wouldn't see anything work.
I will say the one thing I think is kind
of ridiculous is um
that people get rejected from PhD
programs over not having great grades.
It's like
I almost like question if if you do have
perfect grades coming out of undergrad,
I almost question what the hell you've
been doing with your time.
Okay,
this replicable
Not precisely.
A heck of a lot more stable though,
right?
interesting. It breaks with four update
epochs. Really?
This noise
didn't break.
The whole point of these
Yeah, literally no signal in there. None
at all.
The heck?
That's like bizarre.
You also shouldn't need um
need that number of update epochs for
freaking cartpole. I mean cartpole
should be solved in like a tiny number
of steps. This shouldn't be remotely a
challenge.
where it's like one of the only damn
fields where you can have worked in the
space for 10 years. You can have like
very deep knowledge on a ton of
different things in this space and like
literally basic algorithm implementation
from scratch. Good luck. Not going to
work.
Is there like do I have like an extra
log or something? I've checked this so
many times.
I don't know what else it would be.
This shouldn't be important, right?
It literally is random when you start
it. Anyways,
This actually does tell me sample reuse,
right?
Update frequency. Is it four?
I guess it is totally possible, but it's
just like a crappy algorithm that you
have to crank the uh
compute on, right?
But 8x that's only like um
x more than on paul
You know, it's really not that much
code.
There's really not that much space for
stuff to be wrong. Um,
particularly for it to be doing worse
more samples.
I mean, still like, come on. It's more
stable than it was, but it still it
doesn't freaking solve cart pole. Take
what else is in SACE doesn't even have
like prioritize replay or anything by
default, right?
It just has um
it just has like a circular buffer
thing.
There anything else I haven't messed
with?
Feel like I've messed with everything.
Why does it take so long for it to start
learning like anything?
the QET like the architecture is pretty
dumb but like
freaking cartpole
Yeah, it's freaking cartpole. It
shouldn't matter.
fun.
Got to check one small thing.
Do I just have like crazy hyper prams or
something? But there really aren't even
that many hyper prams with this, right?
Literally, we've cut out almost all the
hypers.
This massively like No. Right. There's
no way,
It shouldn't be this brittle at this
scale.
Like basically, you literally can solve
this problem for reference just by
behavioral cloning the best lucky
segments that you get.
I'm giving it on policy data pretty
much, which should be better than
normal.
There should be like a best case
scenario for it pretty much. It should
be super easy
to have this solve.
Like look, if I got this to solve long
and like decent enough on breakout and
then I have to tune it, that's one
thing. This is just not doing
remotely close to how well I would
expect it to.
I mean, do we have to think about epochs
here?
I mean, we know that this is sensitive,
right?
Oops.
We know that this is sensitive.
Okay,
there you go. So, it's really really
sensitive to um
the uh the update
interval here. It's still not stable, by
the way.
Why doesn't this give you a stable
solve?
Let me go double check. make sure that
the uh the reward thing is what I think
it is.
I want to just be sure that I haven't
screwed this up.
Okay, I think that this is confirmation,
right?
Just can't learn
That's confirmation I had it right this
way
is the one I would expect anyways
Let's see. Can we get away with updating
this every eight?
That the play
see this completely crashes. It
doesn't learn a single thing.
Okay, at least this is like reasonable,
right?
best paper at RLC besides my own work
and my friend's work, I assume.
Honestly, there really wasn't anything
stand out
that I was like super excited to go look
at.
I mean, it it started optimizing for a
little second,
but it's still like
Do I not have like some major bug in
Yeah.
and talk RL
get the shilling down. Oh, that was like
a just a super clumsy impromptu
interview. If you want to watch my
actually properly prepared talk, uh it's
on the neural MMO YouTube.
like that. I'm actually proud of.
That was a good talk.
Is there any other major details
I'm missing? I don't
hang on. I don't think like I really
don't think so.
I mean, I guess the uh
we're using really crappy nets, but
shouldn't matter that much. Maybe for
pong and stuff it does.
Let's just at least get it like one
extra hidden layer.
Well, didn't break it for um ppole at
least initially.
I mean, what's the deal with this? Is
this just a stupid algorithm that you
just like have to crank a ton of compute
into before it solves even simple
problems but scales better?
Like
It's annoying because like this is like
I've pushed it to a point here where I
can't be positive it's correct. So I
can't say oh yeah the algorithm just
sucks because I don't know if I have a
bug.
I don't think so at this point.
Solves the simple end.
I've like roughly calibrated it as well.
The update frequency
It only solves freaking cart pole and it
doesn't even fully solve that.
Well, no, this one wasn't doing well
with neural MMO.
It was a different algorithm.
This got up to like 550 whatever.
Doesn't sell breakout
You know, I really thought that I was
going to be able to get something
quickly that at least did like okay, and
I thought, you know, maybe I won't be
able to tune it as good as my algorithm
is.
Like the puffer baseline is just
incredibly
It's like an incredibly tough one to
beat
cuz everything out there is just like so
incredibly ludicrously laughably slow by
comparison, All right.
Does anybody see a bug? I don't see a
bug.
Like it looks to me like I have this
pretty reasonable
value.
basically identical code.
I'm actually here.
Let me commit this.
Guess I ris I uh I I named it wrong a
little bit.
Fine.
Um,
doesn't look like it's working to me.
I figured we'd check the reference
implementation, right?
Maybe it's just like stupidly stupidly
slow. Maybe that's the deal.
I think I might have undersold puffer li
a little bit when I say a thousand times
faster
because now this is like 5,000x faster,
right?
This is literally running under 600
steps per second with like tiny networks
on the fastest possible environment on a
5090.
This is the reference implementation as
well.
So, um,
this thing just not
Have I been here like trying to match
an algorithm that just doesn't freaking
work?
This is actually now at um close to the
steps that I did mine for.
And my version's actually better than
this.
I mean, I feel somewhat better about
this,
Supposed to be a batch size of 32.
Maybe it's Maybe it needs the tiny
batch. I thought it's going to be even
slower.
It's going to be kind of funny to me if
this only works with tiny little batches
of data.
This norm is not good for um
and I caught a bad norm.
Maybe it does work.
This is such an easy problem like
it should insta solve.
Let's
I'm trying to make sure I don't have
like some screw up from um puffer. I
don't think I do though.
It's weird. It's like It is actually
noisy though.
The segments are really noisy,
but it is learning.
It's funny though. It does actually take
it like several minutes
to solve freaking uh cartpole.
So I mean if this is supposed to be the
sample efficient algorithm
and this is what it does.
So noisy that it's like
it's still getting bad
bad segments at this point.
Nothing else I'm missing, right?
I think so.
I mean, okay, we see that this just
continues to bounce around a ton,
but it does do something. Let's just
make sure there's not
do pong real quick. Cuz
if this solves faster then it's like all
right there's something screw Okay.
if I tried to implement myself and I
used like one of the best reference
impleations
and then what would that imply
basically that a lot of these control
tasks they're used on are just like
really stupid really data constrained
problems
not a single episode
the reward.
Yeah, this is bad. This is a It fails
pong.
The fact that they actually got this to
do anything though.
I don't understand why there's this much
of a
a discrepancy. Like I'm literally seeing
this do nothing across both my own
implementation
and uh the clean RL1.
Oh, you know, I wonder who implemented I
wonder if they did it off of this one
and they got a bad uh a bad port of it.
I'm down to do other stuff. Like I'm
down to try this
Uh yeah, this is stuck at -21.
Okay.
Did you figure it out? Try four. No. Um
I think it just sucks.
All right, we'll do the from this, I
guess.
predict state and reward
given state and action.
What in the hell did this thing try to
Welcome.
Oh, wait. This is actually easier cuz
this actually takes num actions at
hidden size, right? And it's
Okay. Okay. And then there's a policy
function,
Let me make sure I actually understand
what they're doing here.
replaces MCTS with sampling based
gumball search.
Oh no, it couldn't. Ray Ray and freaking
Hydra.
Do they use the MCTS though in the uh
the eval loop or no?
or do they only use MCTS
in training?
function supervised learning method of
using the true reward.
over here
monitor.
I'm going to see what I can do about
Yes.
is dynamics, right?
Is dynamics
state action and outputs. Next state
action.
Yes, it does.
Right. So, you have to give it the
action from the previous time step, I
suppose.
Oh, it outputs
reward, not action.
Duh.
Let's just see if I can get a dynamics
model uh to be trained jointly with
the environment for now uh with the
policy for now. So for this you need to
do
Well, actually you just train the policy
as normal, right? You use the policy as
normal
and then you just add in an extra
dynamics, right?
So
8s
Okay. And do like this.
And then we do
dynamics.
Obviously there's no planning or
anything.
Okay. So, you just have this auxiliary
thing, right?
And this does not get in the way at all,
obviously.
and then they
sample action.
Wait, I thought that they don't they do
this. Do they do this during training or
just during um the collection of
actions?
Is this
is this totally different from dreamer?
forms planned planning. Yes.
But then it does this to pick better
actions, right?
I can just figure out how this planning
thing works. So you take H.
H gives you state.
Okay. So we change it so that policy
policy takes state right
Okay,
let's do uh encode observations.
I returned everything correctly. That's
weird.
Well, we haven't made a huge ton of
research progress today,
but you can't say it was for lack of
trying.
I've been pretty well focused up today.
I guess I've been somewhat biased
against how world modeling works since
we spent a whole bunch of time trying to
replicate the dreamer paper and it was
kind of crap.
See about this instead.
search has always made more sense to me
than um
streamer style stuff. Anyways,
I guess I would feel kind of stupid
anyways if there were just a bunch of
free winds lying around
being this crap.
Okay,
still good. Still trains.
We have a world model as part of this
now
with an LSTM.
Yeah. So, the the thing that we don't
know yet
is how we're going to do all the search
crap.
So I can't tell are they are they
basically using the model to like the
planning model to get better actions
fast
or are they training on it as well?
They say that they have there's a Q
function though as well, isn't There.
So they have this tree search thing.
I saw the function in here.
This is the hard part.
Yeah, I don't understand how this uh
this only has the policy.
They're call they're like calling
something weird a policy, I think. Are
they just calling it the probability
vector over uh over actions?
This takes in the model batch size.
dates, root values, root policy logic.
It's a pretty messy looking
implementation.
and I should be able to figure out how
this thing works
It doesn't seem like they have um
they must have a
model
Not the agent, dude. You have a train
function. That's not the agent.
Oh yeah, they have it.
This code I guarantee is super slow
Main thing I need to understand I think
is the um
if I understand the MCTS
description is just not helping me.
Nor is their code.
Oh, I think they don't actually have a
policy. I think they have um
Okay,
I don't think they have a policy
network.
I mean, I could technically try this.
The thing is, I know for a fact this
paper is [ __ ]
At least like the reasoning in most of
it is [ __ ]
I mean, I could very easily.
Do you know exactly why? I mean, we ran
20,800 hours worth of ablations on that
thing. We've got a pretty good idea, I'd
say.
to add in like the auxiliary planning
here.
thing is like
I mean I could Right.
It's tough cuz I've been bitten so badly
by this paper,
Like the result is very good, but this
absolutely should not have been
published with um
the way that it is cuz it's like half
the paper is long.
It is actually a decent baseline though
because it's way simpler to implement
specifically what part. Uh, I know that
the all the little tricks that they add,
like the little tricks that they
proposed are essentially just like
random clever sounding things applied to
reinforce because they didn't have a
strong baseline. What's the advantage of
off policy besides experience replay?
That's the advantage and that's a very
important one.
In my mind, it makes sense that search
works. It actually it doesn't. In my
mind, it doesn't even make sense that
this necessarily works.
Yeah. Like all this crap is wrong.
Um,
yeah, that problem bet is search is like
monstrously complicated to implement.
replay same end port for different
agents. So I don't know what you mean by
that.
Yes, it does work for num ms greater
than one,
but he asked for different agents, not
different ends.
So presumably it's something different
that he wanted.
Dreamer V3.
Well, that and Efficient Zero.
I actually like the formulation in
Efficient Zero a lot more. It makes
sense to me that it works. Um, I think
it's backed by a lot more as well. It's
just horrendously complicated
because making search efficient with
like batch to reinforcement learning is
not easy.
I mean, search on its own is like
already kind of non-trivial to implement
like in like a good MCTS.
It wouldn't be that bad honestly, but
doing it in a context of neural nets is
freaking hard.
849.
I'm going to pick this up tomorrow. I
think
Okay.
I've tried so many different things
today. Um,
this was the
result of the off paw
or the buffer.
I know their code is slowed.
This does quite a bit better.
At the very least.
We found out that there really aren't
any easy wins in offpaul.
Uh the whole kind of the vast majority
of the offpaul work is just super
freaking cursed. Honestly,
breakout is supposed to be the easy task
bet, but
it's kind of a mess that it's this
screwy.
Also, literally, I under I undersshot
when I said puffer is a thousandx
faster.
Like literally some of these offpaul
methods, they're not even set up by
default for batched learning. It's crazy
You'd literally be faster on CPU under
that setup. for like small networks.
Crazy.
Okay, though. Um,
it's almost 6. I am hungry. I got to get
food.
I'm going running tomorrow
and get myself
situated
and then uh I will be back on Monday.
I'm going to try to allocate as much
week as much of next week as possible
to working on all this stuff.
We shall see.
Now this really freaking bothers me
though.
The fact that this
is even like possible that this works is
just that really bothers me.
Expert recording.
Yeah, that works. That's super easy. Bet
it. Yeah, but it shouldn't be worse than
um on policy is the thing.
Wow. Okay, folks. For those of you who
have spent Saturday watching me uh bang
my head against all this research, I did
a lot of different things today.
Thank you for tuning in.
Everything I do is right here at
puffer.ai
free. It's open source part of the repo.
Helps me out a ton. You want to get
involved Discord right here. Other than
that, you can follow me on X.
Uh for more reinforcement learning
content,
whole bunch of articles here for
beginners. Click the uh follow button
wherever that is. All right.